[Musique]
rétro tiennent une bougie bonjour
présentez-vous succinctement jusqu'à
olivier iteanu 51 ans avocat puis
généralement je triche et jusqu'à el
badr essence tricheurs en augmentant
n'en mangent diminue enfin ça fait 25
ans arrêté c'est que ça fait 25 ans donc
j'ai dédié mon activité depuis l'origine
aux technologies d'information et
j'essaye de faire de mon mieux ça dure
katie did aussi vous êtes intervenu
contraire de dossiers drôle de manie
technologies d'information comme je les
dis on va dire que ça tourne autour de
trois grands thèmes
contrefaçon malfaçons est ce qu'on a
pris jusqu'à récemment la fraude
informatique maintenance et la sai on va
dire la cybercriminalité vous êtes les
avocats d'un dossier qui sur internet et
nos mails dossier bluetouff est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en parler un peu plus
en détail c'est un arrêt a été rendu par
la cour d'appel de paris récemment et
qui a fait un peu grand bruit puisque
après que nous ayons obtenu la relaxe
du dénommé bluetouff devance calvo
actional de créteil bien que d'appel
infirmé la décision et a condamné le
prévenu donc le touche pour maintien
frauduleux dans un système de traitement
automatisé tenez et
pour résumer très schématiquement
dossier est un très grossièrement
évidemment quelques mots en gros nous
tout est accusé pour ratera une requête
naturel sur google d'avoir eu accès à
des documents d'une agence de l'état la
ss pour pas la nommer deux mains de la
sûreté publique avoir eu accès à ces
documents et puis on a pris connaissance
et avoir fait à quelques articles de
presse sur des comptes rendus ou des
présentations fait dans des groupes de
travail de la ss et le délit précis qui
a été reproché à bedous fait qu'à donner
la condamnation braquo est de paris c
est ce qu on appelle le délit de
maintien frauduleux dans un système de
traitement automatisé de données c'est
un article du code pénal l'article 323 1
qui condamne au peine maximale pour ce
délit de deux ans de prison et de 30000
euros d'amendé
les personnes qui sont donc
coupables de ce délit bon ne nous sommes
maintenant devant la cour de cassation
formé un pourvoi on remettre mémoire les
prochains jours et nous espérons obtenir
que c'est un respect qu'elle s'est dite
moi est ce que google a été poursuivi 1
quant au sila est ce que nous coûte duel
a été saisie à ce qu'il a été prévenu
qu'est ce que vos pronos médian alors
google poursuivi dans google
effectivement à avec ses robots avaient
recensé un lien qui dirigèrent
s'est contenu qui était mis à
disposition du public
probablement a certainement parce que ça
a été reconnu par la suite par erreur de
la part de la nes mais google n'a pas
été poursuivi ça c'est certain prévenue
probablement à part les clameurs de la
foule sur internet je pense que google
n'a pas été interrogés ne figurent pas
au dossier comme même pas thème témoin
auditionné comme témoin par la police en
l'occurrence c'était la direccte une
centrale du renseignement intérieur le
décès
une enquête de police compte tenu de la
personne de l'art du plaignant date 16
donc ni poursuivis ni interrogé en tout
cas officiellement en figurant pas au
dossier prévenu peut-être et est ce que
le juge a soulevé le fait que peut-être
je l'aï copié vous si les fichiers sur
ses serveurs basés aux états unis alors
ça c'est un point qui a pas été la
mesure google était pas présent
aux audiences puisque une série dont les
audiences correctionnelles le tribunal
la cour refont instruction
certaine manière de la faire rôle
enquête en l'occurrence cette question
n'a pas été traité et puisqu'il n'ya
n'était pas présent n'était pas convoqué
dans la logique du parquet qui a
poursuivi bluetouff
effectivement c'était des questions qui
auraient pu se poser qu'est-ce qui leur
client risque
ils risquent
les peines prévues à peine maximale
prévue par le délit qui lui est reproché
son de lady de deux heures de
deux ans d'emprisonnement par nos
maîtres de 30000 euros d'amendé et peine
maximale
bon ce n'est pas une théorie est que
dans la mesure où dans la sphère et
c'est un peu ce qui nous a choqués
affaires bluetooth
même si techniquement ça n'empêchait pas
faire au parquet de poursuivre ce
dossier vous n'avez pas de victimes
vous avez un plaignant à l'origine nice
n 16 s'est pas constituée partie civile
a aucune des deux audiences au tribunal
d'appel en tout cas pas constituer celui
là ne forcément pas la cour d'appel il
n'y a pas trouvé leur public à ma
connaissance par exemple n'est question
santé publique sont traités par cette
agence aurait pu imaginer qu'elle est
problématique de santé publique se pose
dans ce dossier dans les documents ont
été retrouvés par tout ça n'est pas non
plus le cas et donc au final on a
une question principe ou une position
une posture qui a été prise par le
parquet contre bluetouff qui sur le plan
encore une fois de l'état d'esprit dans
lequel doit être donné une composition
pénale nous nous choque et effectivement
ça a été dit notamment pendant clients
il y a vu un certain acharnement et cela
pose des questions par rapport à son
propre statut même s'il n'est pas
journaliste professionnel il a écrit il
a écrit sur des affaires sensibles comme
par exemple les affaires d'un exactement
la faire un v6 et la vente on va dire
d'outils de surveillance électronique à
la libye de kadhafi diggle vous parlez
de gueule oui et donc il a écrit sur des
sujets sensibles
et évidemment on ne peut pas s'empêcher
de
rapprocher cette situation de celle
qu'il vit donc qu'elle ait procédé
observé pour une personne un individu
car cette physique la particulier
visant une procédure judiciaire à
particules pédales c'est une épreuve et
c'est une épreuve qui dure dans le temps
c'est d'affaires qui dure maintenant
depuis plus d'une année
pour bluetouff est donc évidemment c'est
quelque chose de difficile à lire ce
qu'il faut ce qui va être qui laisse des
traces dans votre vie en ressorte pas
d'une affaire pénale comme on était
avant et donc cette épreuve là parce que
vous sentez pas un bouc émissaire c'est
plutôt une carence de formation de un
juge ou quand on quand on entend que le
juge c'est le juge une procurant qui
google god le
oui c'est effectivement il ya eu lorsque
la callas au tribunal correctionnel n'a
pas et matic ne s'est pas posée mais il
se trouve que l on appelle effectivement
il ya eu des comptes rendus d'audience j
étais je peux confirmer la véracité de
journalistes présents qui ont été
effectivement choqué frappé étonné
effectivement vous avez dit par une
utilisation ou google
logeant pour le guide wagon il ya eu un
certain nombre
de mots prononcés par celui qu'on
appelle le conseiller rapporteur qui
rapporte la sphère en audience publique
qui est celui qu'il ait qui a étudié le
dossier avant que la cour
finalement du siège qui montrait
effectivement on va dire une certaine
distance vis-à-vis méconnaissance une
deux internet devront peut-être mais que
des sens c'est pas à moi non plus j'ai
maintenant j'ai déjà répondu à ces
questions quand on me la poser c'est
vrai
que la corde les connaissances c'était
assez manifeste mais ça n'empêche pas
on ne demande pas un magistrat qui
traite de droit du bâtiment d'être un
maçon on ne demande pas non plus d'être
un geek retraite de technologies de
l'information c'est vrai que peut-être
me sert la justice devrait faire un peu
plus d'efforts il évite des magistrats
parce que peut-être la différence
notamment les services de police où on a
très peu spécialisés professionnaliser
peut-être plus les services de police
que la magistrature peut-être qu'il ya
un effort à faire mais ça n'empêche pas
quand même un mec ou et des magistrats
ce statut et c'est ce qu'ils ont est ce
que le client a reçu le soutien des
journalistes professionnels
est-ce que client a eu un appui est ce
que il a reçu beaucoup de soutien
effectivement alors pas de la profession
organisée on va dire des ministres
organisé pas de la corporation pas à ma
connaissance
maintenant on a eu des réactions après
l'arrêt de la presse on va dire
organiser de la corporation je pense en
particulier à mediapart et à son
directeur qui se sont exprimés
publiquement sur la condamnation oui
effectivement il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
de soutien mais on peut pas dire que
papa de la profession organisée pas de
là que vous avez dit la corporation
jallet gestion j'ai une question à vous
poser concernant la loi de programmation
militaire est-ce que vous pouvez donner
votre avis
écoutez pour moi ça peut peut-être
étonné mais cette problématique de votre
programmation militaire doit 18 décembre
2013 qui a été suivi quelques semaines
plus tard par une loi sur la
géolocalisation
sans contrôle du juge
les différentes problématiques 10 ans
contre le jeu je vais avec un contrôle
du bureau du premier ministre alors pour
les voies programmation militaire
effectivement une personnalité désignée
par le premier ministre en coordination
avec une autorité administrative
indépendante qui a terminé je me
rappelle jamais de la désignation exacte
de cette autorité les qui a
effectivement contrôle des interceptions
de sécurité je vais je vais parler sous
votre contrôle ce qu'ils ont pensé que
la loi de programmation militaire c'est
une extension des écoutes
administratives
d'alors enfin vous avez oui c'est une
extension du compte administratif dans
la départ n'a dépassé et a donné comme
cela c'est ça le problème c'est plus de
service qui va se brancher sur la ligne
et qui va écouter ce qu'ils puissent qui
se passe qui va même intercepte
qu'est-ce qui se passe les magyars l'ère
pinault petit qui est terminée voilà là
on est dans le recueil de données on est
dans la captation de données leur curé
de données dit la loi c'est à dire qu'on
va chercher chez des prestataires chez
les intermédiaires techniques on va
chercher des données tout donné ça peut
être découvrir l'électronique des
courriels et des courriers électroniques
ça peut être des données bancaires ça
peut être des mots de passe c'est tout
ça dont il s'agit donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ça alors quand on a un soupçon
parce que c'est ça la réalité c'est ça
d'un déclencheur lorsqu'on un soupçon
sur une personne aidant enquête et on
enquête la condition évidemment que il
ya un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
dans la programmation militaire qui sont
terrorisme international la sûreté
nationale mais également la défense eu
pratiquement économique et culturel de
la france mais égale elle ça veut dire
la contrefaçon en bande organisée et
notamment la fraude fiscale a aussi
rebondi organisait donc on a un ensemble
de délits
assez varié au final et dès que ces
délits sont mis en action que des
soupçons se portent sur une personne de
manière administratif je vais prendre à
une image forte et bien les services de
police ont maintenant la possibilité
également de mettre la main au pot de
confiture d'aller ouvrir les boîtes
électroniques de prendre les cars
l'adresse de prendre les mots de passe
de prendre les coordonnées bancaires et
tout ça avec un contrôle pour moi c'est
clairement assez chaotique quasi
inexistant qui ne donne aucune garantie
aux citoyens on a fait en france avec
dix ans de retard exactement 12 en
retard on a fait la petite soeur de du
patriot act américain qui a été voté
trois semaines apprend des avants après
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001 en
octobre 2001 par l'administration bush à
l'unanimité du congrès donc sénateurs
républicains et démocrates ensemble vous
y voyez à langer
convenu de contre le terrorisme atassi
assez légitime c'est légitime de notre
intérêt à tous c'est pas une menace
virtuelle dans le coup ces menaces
réelles et même si elle est numérique là
le danger que je vois il est à deux
niveaux c'est l'absurde c'est l'absence
ou la quasi absence de garanties des
citoyens qui pose également question aux
etats unis aujourd'hui et je rappelle
que en 2012 le congrès américain a voté
la prolongation pour un certain nombre
d'années et je crois qu'on cinq ans du
patriot act et qui a un sénateur
démocrate c'est la première fois qu'elle
dépose un amendement commandé de plus de
46 au citoyen à skoda et son nom j'ai
pas son nom comme ça et je peux vous je
peux vous donner et bien c'est ta maman
été refusée mais l'amendement était
demandé donc premièrement absence de
garantie est rien deuxièmement et c'est
parti en me criant états unis
la msa lorsqu'elle passe le programme
précis né dans la mouvance et dans la
famille du patriot act et la voix
programmation militaire le message
qu'elle donne aux gens du web et à ce qu
ont signé ce programme dès 2007
microsoft qu'est-ce qui est premier
c'est google c'est facebook c'est à
apple enfin ce sont neuf entreprises et
le tout avec des vies reisen verison
elle dit quoi à ces géants du web elle
dit sur les populations je vous donne un
blanc seing on ne peut pas à la fois
dire à ces gens là vous limitez votre
surveillance et en même temps je veux
vous ne donniez tout donné que vous
allez collectées sur des personnes que
je vais vous désignez pour vous pour
vous est ce que c'est une démarche des
gouvernements pour identifier largement
sa population pour m'appelle sa
population parce que sa population est
en train de devenir un risque pour la
stabilité de l'état elle les pouvoirs
régaliens l'état alors je les aurais
vraiment de temps dirait un l'enfer est
pavé de bons sentiments ok les bons
sentiments c'est des consommateurs et ce
matin semaine j'ai aucun problème lille
au deuxième étage de la vie et de la de
l'immeuble c'est que en dessous la nsa
en dessous la des séries en dessous tous
les services de l'état qui luttent
manière légitime contre toi et tu
sortiras contre la fraude fiscale contre
la contrefaçon un bel arrêt coûte quand
même jouer ici mais les hissent les
falaises des ordinateurs et un étage en
dessous j'avais google vous avez
facebook qui peut sur les populations
mais de manière de plus en plus serrés
et qu'ils ne font pas pour des buts que
je viens de vous dire eux ils font du
marketing prédictif eux ils sont
capables de vous dire que quand vous
levez le matin vous allez vous gratter
l'oreille droite avec votre après avoir
bu un verre d'eau d'hôtel et familiale
sont ils sont ils vont très très loin
aujourd'hui dans les prédictions et
c'est pour ça qu'ils le font c'est pour
le business pour gagner de l'argent et
ces sociétés là on monte un business
model qui implicitement au moins a été
acceptée par la nsa est pas et que les
services de police et autres et encore
quand vous ne me déployé ce constat j'ai
une question qui me vient à l'esprit est
ce que ce n'est pas peut-être une
forfaiture de notre système judiciaire
de nos juges pour protéger nos
concitoyens ou c'est tout simplement de
la compétence pour parler trivialement
ils sont complètement largué le rapport
à la loi de moore qui s'applique aussi
sur le système d'information monsieur
est par définition ils laissent faire
soit conseillé par des lobbys qui sait
l'ampleur des lobbys mon
travail législatif donc pour vous est-ce
que c'est peut-être une démission ou
c'est simplement non je dirais pas être
démission je dirais même pas une
compétition
non je m'aime pas je dirais un an vision
un avion à long terme à un manque de
compréhension en manque de hauteur soit
problématique
parce qu'on est en train de mettre en
place une système de la surveillance
mais comme ça jamais existé dans une
société j'ai écrit un article sur mon
blog qui s'appelle l'arrière grand père
est l'arrière petit-fils disent non à
notre programmation militaire et qu'est
ce que je dis on est dans un système de
votre arrière grand père est descendu de
chez limi sort de sa maison il va chez
son libraire chez son boulanger et vous
avez les services de police qui disent
libramont boulanger tu vas notes et les
heures d'entrée et sortie de soi de ce
monsieur
et quand il va renoncer ni paroles tu
vas la notte et une âme à noter de prix
qui te paye comment ils te paye combien
ils te paye et c'est maintenant d'un
système nos fils ayant secret s'il a
transpiré quand il est complètement un
complètement on est dans un système qui
est celui là aujourd'hui
le boulanger c'est l'intérêt de faire ça
parce qu'il va pouvoir comme vous dites
maps et sa clientèle il est dans son
business model et et voilà c'est son
système ce qui est totalement anormal
c'est que on encourage dans ce dans ce
système là par la mise en place de ces
sociétés aux ailes en train de dire aux
régions aux sites finalement le
boulanger devient auxiliaires de police
et 600 est légitime j'ai tout à fait
j'appelle ça un supplétif vous appeler
hassan auxiliaire c'est moi je lui il ya
deux justices anthony qu'avocat logique
du respect pour le muhr auxiliaire pour
me supplétifs moi donc je dis plutôt un
supplétif mais oui mais c'est ce à quoi
un prisme j'ai assisté récemment de au
dîner annuel d'un une organisation dans
le domaine du cloud computing comment ça
s'appelle qui s'appelle wroclaw france
qui est une très bonne organisation sur
le secrétaire général je vais pas
cracher un sommet il se trouve que c'est
vrai que c'est une organisation très
intéressant c'est pas des choses et on
est dans le cadre de cette dîner on
avait invité notamment outre la dpi la
banque d'investissement voilà un
responsable d'un très grand fonds
d'investissement dans dans la
californie et dans la silicon valley à
lyon j'ai pu j'ai pu nom de cette
personne et cette personne nous a dit
quelque chose qui m'a se rappelle à 10
mois nous aujourd'hui avec la sphère
prisme on ne veut plus entendre parler
gouvernement nous dans dans dans
californie il nous a fait trop de mal
quand j'allais au trail il nous a fait
très mal avec la msa avec prism et c'est
peut-être trail trop de mal au niveau de
la confiance au niveau de la confiance
qu'on parle de ça parce qu'il n'ya pas
de business sans confiance et vous savez
aux états unis c'est celle attaque du
business finalement qui fait réagir le
mieux les choses et je me suis dit
cette remarque là me montre que rien ne
va changer que deux puits prisme et
snowdon rien ne va changer
c'est à dire que
c'est trop facile d'accuser les seuls
gouvernements américains normes
américain lui lutte contre terrorisme et
encore une fois ça me paraît
parfaitement légitime défense est
citoyen autres une menace qui est réel
et je n'ai pas de pas là dessus mais par
ses actes et par ses agissements et par
son manque de vision des choses
finalement il met en face une certaine
surveillance que les que huit mâles ne
met pas en place qui est bien en place
par d'autres et si ces autres si ces
entreprises là ces géants du web ne font
pas leur autocritique et le peuvent-ils
puisque ça veut dire modifier leur
business model modifier leur
modèle économique
et je rappelle que le modèle économique
de facebook et google contrairement aux
apparences comprend deux derniers c'est
pas de faire un moteur de recherche ou
d'éditer gratuitement des solutions de
bureautique 1 on sait très bien ce
marché de la publicité et du marketing
qui les intéressent
à ses sociétaires - un business qui
exige qu'ils
qui passe par la surveillance des
populations et je trouve dommage que les
services de l'état limite par soe est au
contraire encourage ce système je vais
vous poser deux dernières questions la
première sera votre perception tant que
citoyens n'ont peut-être père de famille
en tant que des policiers avocats
qu'est ce qui se passe on en est où on
va jouer dans ce genre à long terme mais
je pense qu'on est aujourd'hui on est
sur un processus de tsunami c'est à dire
que la sphère snowdon ne date que et moi
je l'appelle la sphère snowdon mais en
fait je n'appelle pas habituellement la
fin de semaine parce que pour les uns
commencent à l'affairisme c'est la ferté
landwind oui la rend plus mais c'est
pour moi le problème des par edouard
snowdon mc prisme donc je crois que
c'est un tsunami c'est un tsunami ça se
passe et aborde secousse 1 et ensuite
on a les effets les symptômes
en l'été 2013 les clients de toutes ces
sociétés consignés avec des dessins
depuis ce depuis juin 2013 depuis le 6
juin 2013 et l'article du washington
post avant de guardian lendemain ces
clients-là ses abonnés à ses adhérents
ses membres là peuvent dire ces sociétés
là mon travail
et ça veut dire que la confiance était
et est aujourd'hui de ces entreprises
effectivement elle est aimée chez elle
et on avait des cachets les brèches et
entachée et donc si cette confiance sans
taj héros on a des pour moi des signes
avant-coureurs pratiquement quotidien
voit le nombre de membres facebook en
diminution les achats de cette
entreprise l'argent au hasard témoigne
quand même d'une prise de panique une
prise de conscience des choses or ils ne
peuvent pas évoluer ne peuvent pas
changer de business model c'est le coeur
de leur art de l'ordre de leur réalité
et bien si cette confiance continue
effectivement à
cette défiance continue à augmenter plus
tôt eh bien c'est la société
effectivement les taxes que d'entreprise
les réseaux numériques et l'état c'est
dé ces nouvelles industries de
l'anonymisation qui va se mettre en
place qui va faire que les soigner mon
sac de miser ou quitter les réseaux même
si c'est un mouvement encore une très
minoritaire aujourd'hui on rencontre des
gens qui vous disent ne m'envoyez pas de
courrier électronique quand vous quittez
quand vous quittez les raisons vous êtes
considéré comme suspect d'un an
oui effectivement c'est aujourd'hui très
record c'est normal c'est un
comportement très minoritaire est à
contre-courant à une derrière une
dernière question si vous aviez la
possibilité d'essai un conseil aux
jeunes générations qui nous écoutent
quels conseils vous lors
laisseriez sur internet comme une
bouteille à la mer moi je leur dirai
plus de leur dire l apprenez à être de
stratèges de votre identité votre
identité c'est votre liberté demain et
donc apprenez avec le stratège de notre
identité
mais à traiter un merci merci à vous
oh
l'idée de la commission trilatérale
vient de david rockefeller il ya 35 ans
il a réuni
quelques dizaines d'européens
d'américains d'eau japonais en leur
disant écoutez on a des problèmes en
commun par exemple
les relations avec la chine par exemple
relations avec eux ce qui était à
l'époque l'urss
essayons d'avoir des positions communes
qu'ils soient dans l'intérêt général
j'efface ici une heure avec une promo
d'un master de sciences po et un
échantillon représentatif quelque chose
dont je suis sûr c'est que sur les les
dix jours qui viennent de s'écouler il
ya cinq personnes qui sont venues me
voir en disant tu sais quoi j'ai quitté
facebook est pour beaucoup ils vont 10
et celui des conversations qu'on avait
eue ensemble aujourd'hui ce que jamais
ce qui ferait vraiment génial de la part
de tout le monde sait comment sont à
créer des outils et des produits
alternatifs qui permet de conserver la
neutralité des réseaux et la neutralité
du net au cas où les autres se fermerait
les oules optimiste jean manuel ne se
vérifierait pas
[Musique]